one of the most consistently confronting
and at times embarrassing Concepts that
psychology forces us to consider is that
of an inner child all of us have along
the years made such efforts to become
adults it can be at once grating and
dispiriting to be told that there might
nevertheless still be an inner child
lodged somewhere within us
truth we contain within ourselves a
version of all the people that we have
ever been there is in recessive form
somewhere in the folds of our Natures a
confused teenager a sad child a jealous
or hungry infant no version of us ever
entirely disappears it's merely added to
and buttressed just like an oak tree
that still contains in its rings the
marks of all its former circumferences
furthermore if we follow the
psychological thesis some of our inner
children are likely not to be especially
well they might be dealing with a hurt
that they have no idea how to cope with
they might have suffered a loss without
any chance to understand who and what is
to blame they might be lonely distressed
or ashamed
despite their pain it isn't that the
inner child's cries are in any danger of
breaking through into the public realm
and that is precisely the problem inner
children cause psychic distress not
because they are too present but because
they are not present enough they have
been too effectively locked away their
cries have been seamlessly forgotten and
ignored they've been pushed into a
soundproof Chamber from which no murmur
emerges and yet still they exist
we are dealing with unwanted Restless
ghosts who have not been appeased or
understood but whose ongoing ignored
unhappiness threatens the course of Our
Lives
the task ahead requires a perhaps even
more grating and obtuse word
re-parenting
the inner child needs to be identified
their distinctive troubles understood
and their pains soothed and be calmed in
a perfect world it would be parents
themselves who would carry out this work
at the time that difficulties arose but
in the real world some of the work gets
left behind and lingers which requires a
bizarre sounding maneuver to correct we
the adults need to become parents to the
children we once were we need to gather
together our adult capacities for
kindness reassurance empathy and warmth
and direct these towards the three or
five or fifteen-year-olds who still
exist in our minds we need to take stock
of these young people's sorrows and help
them in a way they were not helped at
the time in the name of helping
ourselves right now because we are
standing on their shoulders and can only
be as stable as they are
it is when we can directly imagine what
a good and kind person might have said
to us and yet when we are simultaneously
aware of how little anyone did actually
say that we might be overcome with
compassionate tears for our former
selves we may register a trapped sadness
that at last has an opportunity to be
seen worked through and expunged we
might feel a lot lighter afterwards and
we might then regularly perhaps late at
night repeat the exercise revisiting our
inner child and bringing them an extra
dose of comfort and tenderness so that
they and we for we rest as a collective
might sleep more easily
we probably all know well enough how to
treat real children around us
true Liberation awaits us when we
finally learn to treat the children
inside us with as much tolerance
patience warmth and encouragement